hello good morning and welcome to safety
Ridge on Sunday Rishi Cenac has lost one
of his closest allies so Deputy Prime
Minister Dominic Raab resigned after
saying on this program he would quit if
a bullying allegation was upheld and
that means the Prime Minister who
promised a government of Integrity has
now lost three cabinet ministers in less
than six months which leaves of course
an easy hit for the opposition this is a
government distracted by Scandal at a
time when inflation is still above 10
percent pretty dangerous of course with
the local elections next week and a
general election next year well on the
program this morning
just a moment for the government will be
hearing from the new Deputy Prime
Minister Oliver dowdon the man who
stepped into dominant Robb's shoes for
labor we'll talk to the party in Shadow
work and pension secretary Jonathan
Ashworth
and with local elections 11 days away
will be joined live by the leader of the
liberal Democrats that is Ed Davey
plus with inflation stubbornly in double
digits and the price of food rising at
nearly double that we'll take a closer
look at the economy with the former bank
of England's Chief Economist Andy halde
[Music]
thank you
now back in February when we spoke to
the then Deputy Prime Minister this is
what dominic Rob said
well your resign I'm not going to start
speculating on uh what the uh outcome
might be again you're asking me to
comment on the subject matter I'm not
asking you to comment on this project
myself I'm asking you to find out what
what you will do but it's a hypothetical
question so I've got two different
outcomes well look let's see it says I'm
not in control then you won't resign so
what will happen if you do if you're not
clear well allow me to respond in the
right uh way at the right time of course
look if an allegation of bullying is
upheld I would resign
well in the end he did stick to what he
said on this program and on Friday
dominant Robb resigned after a report
that found he engaged in abuse or misuse
of power to undermine or humiliate staff
now that means there's a new Deputy
Prime Minister Oliver Darden whose day
job is cabinet office Minister and
Chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster and
I spoke to him just a few moments ago
thank you very much for being on the
program congratulations on the new job
um we'll get into the reasons for the
appointment in a moment but first if you
could just give us an update on what's
happening with Sudan France deciding to
evacuate their citizens are we going to
do the same
well well thank you Sophie and uh the
situation in a respect of Sudan is
clearly a rapidly moving and complex
situation our priority is to support
British Nationals now the minister of
defense is acting in support of the
foreign office but clearly you wouldn't
expect me to comment for security
reasons on uh the the current situation
in terms of movements on the ground sure
I get you don't want to get into the
details of movement but at the same time
you know the US has said that they're
evacuating different amounts of France
has come out to say they're going to
evacuate Nationals as well are we
looking at evacuating citizens well as I
said we have got uh the the ministry of
defense is supporting uh the the foreign
office you wouldn't expect me to get
into uh what is is going on at a ground
level but what can I what I can say is
that we are at first of all it's a what
I would say is a very different
situation to for example the situation
that you saw in Afghanistan for a number
of reasons first of all this situation
has arisen uh very rapidly and uh
secondly we just don't have the kind of
uh scale of resources on the ground that
were there in Afghanistan but clearly we
need to make sure that uh we support our
British Nationals at the moment the
advice to to British Nationals is to
make sure they stay indoors that they
they stay safe and that they get in
contact with the foreign office okay and
we'll continue course talking to the
government as it goes on to see if that
advice changes or if there's any
movement and more that you can tell us
later
um you're testing an emergency alarm
today what's the thinking behind it
well the the job of government is to
keep people safe it's number one uh job
of government and what we are doing is
we're testing an emergency alert so at
three o'clock this afternoon there will
be a siren like sound for about 10
seconds on people's smartphones is about
the same volume as if your phone was
ringing but I would say to people is
this is just a test you don't need to do
anything it's rather like the fire alarm
test is is a bit irritating at the time
but in future people could be grateful
for it because in a real emergency this
could be the sound that saves your life
forgive me it feels something a
bit advertising around this right at
three o'clock when people's phones start
blaring out
we're gonna panic aren't they well I
don't think that's the case we we tested
this for example in the reading area and
there were over 140 000 people involved
in those very positive feedback there
wasn't any Panic at all I have announced
I think on on your program a couple of
weeks ago that this thing was coming
it's very similar to what happens in
other countries whether that's the
United States whether it's uh the Japan
or or Canada they regularly test these
things as well I think it's another tool
in the the toolkit I think most British
people in these situations keep calm and
carry on I'm sure they'll do the same
thing again okay now I it wants to spend
too much time talking about migration
because to be honest it feels as if
every Sunday we have another almost
identical opinion piece by suela
bravaman saying she's going to take on
the courts and she's going to get tough
on small boats but there are a couple of
facts I think it would be useful to try
and find out ahead of the illegal
migration Bill coming to the commons
this week is the Home Secretary going to
be given powers to ignore European
courts if they try to stop deportations
to Rwanda
well I think you're talking about the
so-called section 39 uh Provisions uh
the the Home Secretary uh will be given
a discretion an ability to look at the
circumstances of that uh order from the
European Court of of Human Rights and
will for example consider factors such
as the timeliness of the uh the the
imposition of the order so for example
if it is done at last minute uh and also
the transparency because underlying all
of this Sophie is the same point and by
the way I've I've been out campaigning a
lot I hear this so much from people
people want us to get control of our
borders stop this file traffic and stop
the boats and this is an important
provision as part of much about the
arguments for and against I'm just
trying to nail down exactly the facts
right so there will be a discussion
given to the Home Secretary to
effectively ignore European court
rulings well there will be a section 39
discretion now I'm not saying that that
will give the the Home Secretary carte
blanche to overall uh rulings what I
would say is that first of all we are
engaging very closely uh with the
European culture we're making very good
progress but I think it's right that the
Home Secretary should have a discretion
so for example we don't have this
situation where at the very last minute
uh an order is imposed those are the
sort of factors the Home Secretary will
be able to consider will there also be a
move to open up more safe and legal
routes because that's something that
other people are really concerned about
that it's very difficult for people to
actually legally claim Asylum
yes well the first thing to say is that
uh We've allowed over half a million
people
so it's an important point of contact it
is an important point of context on this
which is that in this country we've been
able to allow uh ukrainians Hong Kong
Nationals uh Afghanistan Nationals in
now of course I want us to be able to be
in a situation where we can create more
routes for people to come into this
country
what comes first is making sure that we
get control of our borders and we stop
this vile trafficking of people across
the the English Channel only uh
profiting criminal gangs once that's
that control of once we get control of
that stop the boats then we will have
more capacity to be able to extend our
kindness and generosity as a nation
which I'm very proud of even further
that sounds like a no to me then no move
next week to open up more safe and legal
routes to the UK
um let's move on to other issues because
as I said it feels like every week we're
talking about um this issue
is Dominic Raab a bully
well the Prime Minister asked Adam tolly
to conduct a detailed investigation I
think it was about 48 pages long he set
out the facts of what happened in a very
clear way there's nothing further I can
add to that interpretation what I can
say though is that Dom promised that if
there was an adverse finding against him
he would resign I've worked with domon
uh over a number of years particularly I
remember the time when he took over from
Boris when he was incapacitated I know
that Dom is a man of his word and he
resigned and as the Prime Minister said
I think that was the right thing to have
done he did he made that promise on this
program that if the bullying complaint
was upheld he would resign so if he
hadn't made that commitment do you think
he would still be in a job well so
that's a hypothetical uh situation uh
the Prime Minister asked Adam to conduct
this situation it was it was um it was a
very comprehensive piece of work it
dealt with each of the allegations uh
against him and went into the facts of
those
the situation as to whether the Prime
Minister had to make a decision on that
didn't arise because Dom had always
promised it was an adverse finding
against him he would resign he's a man
of his word and he stuck by that would
you like to see him back in cabinet well
I think Dom has
um a huge amount that he has offered at
this country in the past clearly
decisions as to who is in the cabinet or
not are purely The Preserve of the Prime
Minister now Dominic Robb has blamed
activist civil servants who are trying
to block reforms and in The Observer
Today it says the government's
considering allowing ministers greater
powers to appoint their own civil
servants do you think there was a case
for that
well we keep all of these things under
view I think it was actually an article
by Francis Moore who was a predecessor
in the cabinet office and I think it's
important that we we look at Civil
Service uh appointments on an ongoing
basis but I'm pretty confident that uh
at the moment ministers are able to give
clear instructions to civil servants and
to get things done and that has to
continue and I I can say that certainly
there won't be any dropping of my high
standards from the civil servants that
work for me and the reason for that is
that we're here to serve the British
people and we must continue to do you
think that Rob is wrong then to Mr
rather's Wrong then to talk about the
civil servants in the way that he does
because he is talking right about
activists civil servants he's
effectively saying that they're out to
get him
well I didn't live Dom's experience I've
I've served both as an advisor in the
past and for a number of years as a
cabinet minister I've always found that
if you give clear instructions to uh
Civil Service of course you can have
frustrations and believe me I've had my
frustrations as well but I've also seen
for example I think that at the height
of the covid crisis when all of our
theaters were were looking down my civil
servants work Relentless with me
literally with me to get that two
billion pound cultural Recovery Fund
civil servants can deliver but I do not
want to see any diminution in the
ability of ministers to expect high
standards of their officials because in
the end we're serving the British people
and we must continue to I mean it's
important to say that some of the
complaints against Dominic robbed said
that he would behaved in an intimidating
fashion with unreasonably and
persistently aggressive conduct when
you've spoken before about a painful
woke psycho book psychodrama do you
think the reaction to dominant Rob is an
example of the painful work psychodrama
well I I I think there are many
challenges with uh work and you've seen
many speeches from me uh in the past on
that I think in respect of the the Civil
Service what I have seen is that if you
give clear instructions to to civil
servants you can expect uh them to
respond to that and I don't want to see
any change in that because it is
essential that we deliver people I want
to talk about this quite seriously now
because there have been nine Justice
secretaries since 2015 that's more than
one a year and I think we can just look
now at the state of the Crown Court
backlog I mean the latest figures put
the backlog of cases at over 60 000
there's no sign of this coming down and
I guess the concern here is that this is
yet another conservative government
distracted by Scandal and not getting to
grips with really pressing issues that
the country is having to face well what
I would say is I think that and I don't
think anyone disputes us that Don Rob
did a very effective job as the Justice
secretary and there's an excellent
successor in the form of Alex chalk who
has many years
the context of this Sophie I think
because as you and America are just not
helping I think as you and all your
viewers will know is there is a reason
for this high level of backlog which is
the inability of the courts to operate
as normally during the the that's not
true because
of course there were challenges but it
it has been made a lot worse by uh
covert we are working through it for
example extending court hours the
continuing digitalization process for
our courts so work is ongoing on that
there are there are deep problems which
we're seeking to address I don't think
that the the change in the person of the
Lord Chancellor Justice secretary is
going to impact that I mean I guess you
say that it shouldn't impact it people
will draw their own conclusions because
it does feel that we are effectively
spending so much time and energy talking
about these ongoing kind of scandals if
you like it another the findings from
the review Into the appointment for the
BBC chairman Richard Sharp uh due
imminently now of course you'll say this
as a matter for the BBC but it's not
that simple is it because concerns
around the appointment of Richard Sharp
are about the fact that he failed to
declare his involvement in facilitating
a loan to Boris Johnson who went ahead
to recommend him for that job
if there is found to be wrongdoing in
that process should he step down
well so if you won't be surprised for me
to say to you that there is this ongoing
investigation into the the nature of his
appointment and I'm certainly not going
to preempt that by by saying how Richard
Sharp should respond to it what I will
say is that as the the Secretary of
State responsible for his appointment uh
I think we as a department went ran the
appointment process well we ran it
transparently and I have every
confidence that the inquiry will uphold
that process as being the right it
wasn't that transparent was it because
he didn't declare the loan he's admitted
himself and have had to apologize for it
also concerns about the recruitment
process were raised before when you're a
culture secretaries you say in October
2020 there was a letter from the former
BBC chairman sir David Clementi to you
who said the committee is also concerned
about the appointments of my successor
as chair we were concerned about the
very strong press reports that the
government even before the job had been
advertised was in discussion with a
preferred candidate including discussion
about salary
I mean you can see how this looks and I
know this wasn't about Richard Charles
itself but you can see how this looks
right the government trying to press its
own candidates on people who agrees
politically with some would worry that
this is them effectively trying to
control the BBC how did you respond to
this letter
uh well as of you often do on this show
and I don't blame you you flash up
someone something on the the screen
behind me uh and unless you want me to
pause for about 10 seconds to read it
was like raising concerns
finish
this is why there has been an inquiry
set up into the the conduct of the
appointment I have every confidence that
it was a transparent and open process in
terms of this idea that somehow the
conservatives are packing uh public
appointments most of the the complaints
that I found when I was responsible for
for public appointments several years
ago that it was it was this same the
still the same old uh Merry-Go-Round of
Labor cronies who were managing to get
top public appointments I don't think
the facts uh bear out that somehow
conservatives are are skewing the public
appointments process I really don't
think that's the case Okay so we've got
concerns about doing it Ralph concerns
over the BBC and obviously it's a really
smooth things over to show that this is
a scrupulous government that's above any
Scandal Boris Johnson is reportedly
about to put his own father into the
honors list
I mean that is astonishing isn't it
well so if you really wouldn't expect me
to to comment on the honest process
that's an independent process which I'm
I'm not that independent on that's the
whole problem right there's the there is
a there is a set process whereby former
Prime Ministers are able to nominate
people that they wish to have uh on us
and then that goes through a proper
process even if they're family members I
I cannot say one way or or the other on
that so please don't take it one way or
the other that there's a proper process
for that do you not think it would look
odd
father of a former prime minister was
given an honor by his son well so if you
are you're putting forward a
hypothetical it's not that hypothetical
I'm not just plucking this out with
thinner hair I think I think actually we
saw with the
um investigation into the conduct of
John robbers an awful lot of speculation
that turned out not to be the case in
the end and is for precisely that reason
that I don't respond to speculation
understood okay well voters are going to
have a chance to make their thoughts
clear on all this very soon they're
local elections in England and Northern
Ireland in a few weeks and of course you
resigned as conservative party chair
last year in June I can't believe that
wasn't even a year ago after some bad
election results you said someone must
take responsibility I just want to have
a look at the polling uh over that time
because you can see that the polling is
actually now worse for the conservative
party than it was when you uh resigned
if it's this bad on the local elections
do you think Greg hands the party
chairman should have to resign as well
well first of all and I really found
this when I was party chairman
polls come and go they go up and down
key things are the tests of the the
British people and there'll be a test of
the British people uh on the May the 4th
on that election day and that's where
you can see what the results are from
that
of course it's a challenging backdrop
overall the conservatives are still
broadly in a midterm situation and when
we previously fought those seats uh we
were in a different position so there is
an expectation about a thousand or so
seats lost but what I would say is that
my experience of working with with Rishi
sunak as prime minister is he has
brought a calmness and a stability and
an order to government he's methodically
dealing with problems and I'm finding
that people are responding positively to
that of course there are challenges and
of course there's a way to go but I feel
that we are in heading in the right
direction and I I hope that the British
people will respond to that in those
elections which of course are also I
should say on on local issues primarily
thank you very much indeed
all of it out in there the new Deputy
Prime Minister what we were just talking
there weren't we about the local
elections we can get the view from labor
now because the Ponte is going to be
hoping to turn those big Pollies we were
looking at into concrete success at the
coming local elections in England and
there are also ones going on in Northern
Ireland as well of course well let's
speak now to the shadow work and pension
secretary shall we Jonathan Ashworth
good to have you on the program
um I just want to start if I may with
Saddam because there's going to be lots
of our viewers who can be very concerned
about the situation there France already
beginning to evacuate its citizens it
didn't feel uh like from that interview
with Oliver Dowden that the government
in the UK has any plans to do so he said
that we simply don't have the scale of
resources on the ground in Sudan as we
did in Afghanistan would that be a
mistake
well it's deeply concerning what we're
hearing from
Sudan and I'm very fortunate as a
Leicester MP to
represent a small Sudanese Community I
know people are deeply deeply troubled
and alarmed at what they're seeing and
what we're hearing from Sudan
ask the question around evacuations and
so on it does seem a legitimate question
as to why our government is not acting
in the same way that other governments
are acting I hope we can have a
clarification from the foreign office
perhaps in Parliament in the in the
coming days on that front
and the other well we're waiting to see
what that does whether they do do that
as Mr Darren said it's very fast-moving
situation on the ground in Sudan we were
also talking about the illegal migration
bill that is due to come to the House of
Commons next week
um just to clarify how is labor going to
be voting on that
well of course we don't think that this
illegal migration bill is going to
resolve
the problems although we have put down
amendments around those who have come to
the the UK via the uh by the channel
Crossings and uh Terror suspects we
believe there should be a duty upon the
Home Secretary to find those Tower
suspects and Deport them immediately so
we'll be interested to see if
conservative MPS vote for our Amendment
but more broadly of course we don't
think this legislation is going to fix
the problem to fix the problem you
really have to go after these criminal
gangs and people Smugglers you need to
have a very specialist agency properly
resourced that is something that Yvette
Cooper has been pushing for but of
course we want to we want to deal with
these people traffickers who are
bringing people across the channel
because at the moment they're getting
away with it and that is not right
of course no one's been actually
deported to Rwanda yet because it's been
sniled up in the courts so far and what
was very clear from all of it Adam this
morning was that there is going to be
new powers given to the Home Secretary
to ignore what he would say last minute
requests from the European Court to try
and stop deportation flights does labor
think it's acceptable for European
courts to be able to overrule decisions
made in the UK
well across the homes actually is to
send more journalists to Rohana than
actual migrants it's not a scheme that
is going to work it's why we've said we
shouldn't be going ahead with that
scheme and we should be using the money
that would be saved from that and
millions and millions and millions of
pounds of taxpayers money
if I may the specific question was about
we should always follow we should always
follow the role of things
of course we should always uh uh follow
the law we shouldn't be acting out
outside of the law but the point is that
scheme is not working uh quite
self-evidently because as I say the home
secretary's actually more journalists to
Rwanda and we should use the resources
that be have been plowed into that
scheme to invest in a specialist crime
agency to really go after these criminal
people trafficking games I've seen very
senior Tory MPS tweet they'll always be
these criminal gangs there's always be
people traffickers why go after them I
think that's just unbelievable
unbelievable to give these criminals a
free pass labor would get tough and
would deal with these criminal gangs I
guess the difficulty is you know saying
that you'll get tough and saying that
you'll deal with the gangs that's the
easy bit it's pretty difficult isn't it
to actually prosecute or even find that
people traffickers what the government
would argue is that at least they're
trying to do something what is Labor's
plan other than to smash the game which
sounds easy but in practice
but we're prepared to put the resources
in to a specialist criminal criminal
police uh investigatory Force to deal
with our International allies the
conservatives say they're trying to deal
with what are they doing they're not
doing anything and actually we keep
getting press releases and op-eds from
ministers and Tory cabinet ministers
parading around Studios saying they're
dealing with this and actually they
never do they're more interested in
grabbing headlines than actually dealing
with the with the problems on the ground
we've got a plan we'll start by going
after those criminal gangs with our
specialist uh police force would also
deal with the backlog in the Asylum
system as well because there's a huge
backlog in uh in claims what is the
government doing in response they just
Chase headlines week after week
all right let's look at shall we get the
other big story of the week which is the
resignation of Dominic Raab after that
report into his behavior at the ministry
of justice and also at the foreign
office now he has said that he believes
that some civil servants were
effectively out to get him that they
were in his words activists who are
trying to block reforms How concerned
should we be that a senior minister is
saying this about the Civil Service
well look first of all let me say this
you know there's no problem with being
demanding or inquisitorial or pushing
the system hard
I want to be the work and pension
secretary I want to be demanding and
push the system to get people into good
well-paid jobs to lift children out of
poverty to help the disabled people a
million extra disabled people in poverty
I want to push hard and be demanding to
give pensioners security so there's
nothing wrong with that but the report
found that Dominic Robb was intimidating
aggressive and it's not just that he was
a bullying Minister he was also a
failing Minister failing to deal with
the backlog in the courts failing to
deal with the problems in the criminal
justice system and indeed his failures
and with the criminal justice system I
think are symptomatic of a failing
government who after 13 years now all of
our public services are on their knees
and failing so look you know it's right
that Dominic Robb has resigned it calls
into question where she soon acts
judgment in appointing him and I think
it's now the third cabinet minister is
lost so there is a serious questions
about as to why Rishi sunak up pointed
him in in the first place but my biggest
concern is the failing the failing
ministers and their failure in
government
um I just wonder do you think we're at a
bit of a watershed moment when it comes
to workplace culture I now remember a
very you know senior labor politician
and Years Gone by who people said they'd
witnessed him throwing pens staplers
shoving a printer off a desk are things
just obviously it's worth saying that
none of this was at all a director
towards a Dominic ra but do you think
our standard for what is acceptable in
the workplace has changed
I mean people should not feel
intimidated people should not be bullied
people should not be treated in a way in
which humiliates them in the workplace
but there are many many ministers in
this government who don't have
complaints about them so you come so it
is possible to be a government Minister
and not bully your staff
but as I say there's nothing wrong with
being demanding I will be demanding if
I'm the working pension secretary to get
people into good well-paid jobs and lift
children out of poverty you know so it's
right to be demanding when you're
serving the British public but my
biggest concern here isn't just that we
have a bullying Minister we also have
failing ministers and you know we've got
a government which is failing across the
board not just on public services but a
government that is putting up tax on
working people that is forcing people or
leaving people abandoned without the
help that they need within this
desperate cost of living crisis and of
course the biggest failure of all was
when they crushed the economy last year
and millions of families are now paying
more in for their mortgages or in rent
so we've got a government which is
forcing the British public to pay the
price for their 13 years of failure well
that's your pitch I guess isn't it the
local elections we just heard you give
it there I'm sure the government would
question some of what you are saying
there it's a test for cursed armor isn't
it these set of local elections uh
coming up if you want to be the next
prime minister he needs to show that he
can turn the poll lead that he has into
actual seats at a proper poll what would
be a good night for labor
well look I'm not a sofologist and you
know uh and nor am I going to even
around the block of it you know how
these elections work come on uh I've
certainly been around a long time and uh
you'll also know that politicians have
been around a long time don't make
predictions ahead of the election uh
because the only polls are the ones on
polling day but what I would say is this
what we're seeing from the government
and our sort of is a sort of last gas
government who cannot be trusted with
the future nor make amends for their 13
years of failure they cannot be trusted
on tax they cannot be trusted on living
standards they cannot be trusted with
people's mortgages and they most
certainly cannot be trusted with the
criminal justice system and the National
Health Service and as I go around the
country talking to people I have a sense
that people have had enough of the
conservatives and their 13 years of
failure
okay well we'll find out when we uh what
happens at those local elections thank
you very much for being on the program
this morning Jonathan ashworthair from
labor thank you
where you're watching at safety Ridge on
Sunday busy show for us this morning the
new Deputy Prime Minister only a few
days after getting that surprise
appointment shall we say uh he is giving
the tour of the TV studios trying to set
out the position of the government well
let's talk now shall we to some coats
because as usual the take follows this
program just after 9 30 where we can
analyze at the interviews talk through
our news lines but we can get a bit of a
reaction now from uh Sam Sam anything in
particular standing out for you this
morning
oh absolutely Sophie listening to Oliver
Dowden who's now been Deputy Prime
Minister for 48 hours I I just think the
sort of essay question is does this
government turn a blind eye a bit too
much I've been reading this weekend the
new book about Boris Johnson by the
eminent historian uh Anthony Selden and
I'm very struck by two sentences about
when Dominic Robb took over from Boris
Johnson because Boris Johnson was in
hospital one number official number 10
official told Anthony Selden in advance
we were warned about Rob's bullying and
shouting that was years ago years before
Rishi sunak appointed Dominic Raab
Deputy Prime Minister yet here we are
today fighting over quite what Nuance
the report might have been right
listening to Oliver Dowden there's also
a sense that he doesn't want to get
involved in talking about Richard Sharp
the chairman of the BBC he was the
culture secretary when that appointment
was waved through but did that uh go
that appointment follow the rules he
didn't want to talk about whether or not
Boris Johnson's dad's going to get a
peerage he said that's a hypothetical do
voters think that people like Oliver
Dowden can just brush off questions like
this about how they acted in the past
how they acted under Boris Johnson's
regime perhaps or do all of these
relevant issues remain relevant as we
head to the polls next week yeah it does
feel doesn't it these things are kind of
layering up slightly which gives it a
different amount of emphasis uh Stan
thank you very much for your analysis
we'll hear more from Sam later on this
morning still to come on the program as
well in just a moment we are going to be
talking to this man the leader of the
liberal Democrats Ed Davey ahead of
those local elections plus a little
later we're going to hear from the
former Chief Economist at the bank of
England Audi holiday and I always love
doing these interviews with people who
are not as you say on the political
front line because I feel like they can
talk a bit more openly about what they
really think about for example the state
of the economy
[Music]
foreign
actions in England just 11 days away we
can turn to a party now that has built
much of its success on local campaigning
the lead Dems will be particularly
hoping to take votes from the
conservatives and then translate that to
a Westminster election next year or we
can talk now to the live Dam leader Ed
Davey thanks for being on the program
we'll just heard Jonathan Ashworth
saying that look if you're an
experienced politician you won't get
drawn into making predictions or see if
I have any more luck with you what's a
good night for the live Dems and the
local elections
well I think we can make real really
good gains actually Sophie
um the last time these seats before we
made big gains we made over 700 gains
four years ago in these particular
Council Awards but I've been going up
and down the country I've been to
Stockport and greater Manchester I've
been Hull or Yorkshire I've been down to
Lewis and Eastbourne all around the
country and what we're hearing on the
doorsteps is lifelong conservatives
really quite cross they feel they've
been taken for granted they feel the
government is out of touch whether it's
on the cost of living crisis or the NHS
crisis and they feel that the little
Democrats are coming up with really good
ideas they like our candidates who are
it's a really good local activists who
represent their areas really well so I'm
feeling very positive that the the
party's got momentum and I think we will
make good gains okay well that's the
pitch and you're pretty clear at your
election launch what the plan to get
there is you were sort of pictured
driving a tractor through a blue wall so
obviously got on those they're
conservative blue wall of seats in your
sites are you going to go after dominant
rap
well uh Dominic Robb ought to resign as
an MP and face a by-election and if he's
not prepared to do that to enable his
constituency Walton to have a uh the MP
they deserve I think the government
should withdraw the whip from him
otherwise they're sending a message that
the bullying is somehow okay in the
conservative party when it comes to
local elections there's the elmbridge
district council elections in his
constituency I think we will make big
gains from the conservatives in those
council elections and at the next
general election we will defeat uh
Dominic Raab well it's interesting isn't
it because I feel like there's a
tactical question for the legends about
which kind of Voters you go for and it's
very clear from the launch and listen to
what you say that you do see
conservative seats as a particular
Target so does that mean are you to the
right or to the left of the labor party
we are putting forward a liberal
Democrat uh position whether it's on the
economy dealing the cost of living we
were the first party tonight if I may
I'm just gonna jump in because I do kind
of feel if you can't answer that
question some people will be asking what
is the point of the liberal Democrats
you've got to cut through you've a
smallest smaller party the third biggest
party you've got to have a clear message
surely that's always when you've done
best on things such as the Iraq one you
can't even tell me if you're to the
right or the left of Labor
okay no we we have a very clear message
you're defining in terms of left and
right I'm not accepting that definition
I'm saying we have positive positive
policies on the economy uh to help
people with their energy bills to help
businesses who are struggling with their
energy bills we've got really
distinctive policies on the Health
Service let me give you one
um everyone knows that in order to sort
out the NHS we've got to sort out social
care there's 165 000 vacancies in Social
care only the little Democrats have put
forward an idea that there should be a
special minimum wage for carers two
pounds an hour extra on top of the
national minimum wage to deal with that
crisis because if we deal with a crisis
in Social care Sophie that will help a
lot of patients be discharged from
hospital they're waiting days weeks in
hospital when they should be going out
because it's not the carers to look
after them that puts extra pressure on
the NHS it wastes money and is not good
for those patients so liberal Democrats
are coming up with really attractive
policies on our health services on the
economy and that's distinctive from both
the other parties is
I mean I I absolutely concede that
social care is a hugely important thing
in this country but I guess my question
is a time when you need to cut through
as a smaller party is a bit more money
for carers really going to do that if
you look at the latest polling for
example you know you can see the labor
party doing very well compared to the
conservative party in the polling the
lib Dems I mean you're still kind of
bumbling along the bottom and I'm trying
hard to differentiate your line there
between all the other smaller parties
well so if you when we get to actual
elections which I think is really what
matters we are cutting through big time
so the local elections last year which
party made the biggest gains and these
elections were across England Scotland
and Wales it was the liberal Democrats
making the most gains at three palm tree
by-elections in the last two years in
True Blue areas like in Cheshire and
Amsterdam and buckinghamshire it was
liberal Democrats who beat the
conservatives in North Shropshire seek
the territories of hell for 200 years we
cut through and we won that seat in East
Devon in different Honiton last summer
we overturned a majority the biggest
majority ever overturned at a palm tree
by-election in British electoral history
we were getting cut through and beating
the conservatives and what I'm seeing as
I go around the country and talk to
people we are the ones who are getting
the those lifelong stories switching to
us and in vast ways of the country both
of the council elections in May and the
general election whenever it comes
presumably next year it it's liberal
Democrats who are the ones who are best
placed to beat the conservatives and we
will get that cut through and beat those
conservatives looking ahead to next year
the general election which does feel
quite unpredictable
if labor falls short of an outright
majority with the lib Dems enter a
coalition with them
look so if in my job as far as I've said
throughout my leadership is to be
conservative MPS we have a positive
liberal Democrat agenda and that's what
we'll be standing on and you know when I
go around the country and talk to voters
they feel the conservatives have taken
the for granted liberal Democrats are
not going to make that mistake we're
going to work really hard to make sure
we get as many little Democrat MPS back
off the next election and beat as many
concert MPS as possible I could not have
been clearer well you haven't been that
clear in answering the question that I
pose which is would the lib Dems go into
Coalition with labor
well liberal Democrats job is to beat
conservatives next election there are
one of your seats where we're up against
uh labor like Sheffield Hallam but the
vast majority of seats that we can win
the next election in my judgment are
against the conservatives and I want to
focus relentlessly on that I I think the
conservatives have let down our country
very very badly that's what conservative
voters are telling us whether it's only
economy on the Health Service on the the
environment for example I mean here's an
issue we've been cutting through Sophie
the outrageous way that can the
conservatives have allowed water
companies to pump their filthy sewage
into our rivers and seas has really
really angered many many people and it's
been the liberal Democrats leading on
that campaign in Parliament in the local
elections and I'm delighted that many
parts of the media now following were
the issue that liberal Democrats have
first put on that table okay that's a
simple thing if you vote liberal
Democrat you're going to get strong
position on the environment okay I'm
very clear where you are on the water
I'm still not clear about whether you'd
enter a coalition with labor because
some would say that look if you want to
make impact on things such as the
environment then you've got to be in
government would you enter the Coalition
with labor it's a really clear question
yeah and I'm giving you a clear answer
the more liberal Democrats
no because I want people to vote liberal
Democrat to both to come be conservative
and peace and to get liberal Democrat
policies and I've outlined a number of
those policies to you today and that's
the job of political parties surely is
to stand on a set of policies on a set
of values and put them into it to the
electorate and hopefully if you win
seats so MPS can do that in Parliament
if you don't feel able to answer the
question about whether you'd enter a
coalition just just say look I'm not
going to answer that question because I
I'm trying to I'm trying to work out if
I'm supposed to be reading between lines
here or if I just don't get it would you
enter a Clio
it's quite closer because when I go up
and down the country talking to people
on the economy on the Health Service on
the environment that's not what people
are asking me they're asking me how are
you going to deal with without problems
yeah but but yeah I know I know you are
but what I feel is that liberal
Democrats and all politicians frankly
should respond to the electorate make it
clear where they stand on those issues
and not take voters for granted I mean
in many ways your question is taking
voters for granted now I'm not going to
do that I want to make sure that we earn
people's vote over the weeks and months
ahead so at the next general election we
can get rid of this a shocking
government who's failing our country is
just so out of touch with people who
can't afford food bills can't afford
their energy bills and are desperately
trying to get into get that hospital
treatment they need okay thank you very
much indeed Ed David outlining his pitch
ahead of the local elections
uh we'll be talking to the greens uh
next week if you're wondering uh whether
or not a few people ask me on social
media I'll say we'll be talking to them
ahead of the elections in the program
next week
now Russia sunak says that he will halve
inflation as one of his five Pleasures
to voters the problem is this week of
course we found out prices are still
Rising by more than 10 a year and food
inflation is almost double that so
really difficult for lots of people and
the economy isn't growing either which
means we're getting poorer and it is of
course bad news for struggling families
but it's also potentially difficult for
the government now Andy haldane used to
be a chief Economist at the bank of
England he's now the chief executive
officer of the Royal Society of Arts I
spoke to him this week
um thank you so much for being on the
program it's great to talk to you today
so you've just been appointed uh by the
chancellor onto his economics advisory
panel I'm interested to know like given
the kind of economic landscape we're in
what would be your number one piece of
advice to politicians now
hi Sophie I think um you can't look much
further than growth right now
we haven't got any
just at the moment it's been anemic now
for the better part of 15 years in
accounting
that makes all choices difficult if
a growth
becomes your word after the Liz truss
mini Mega budget
how do you
in a responsible way
well I think the key word there is is
responsible
and sustainable
and inclusive
so I think you know what went wrong last
year with the dash for growth is it
wasn't seen as being a sustainable plan
for growth so what would that look like
then well I think ultimately this is
about expanding
how we produce as a country rather than
what we consume as a country
it's about more people being in the
workforce
and it's about those people producing
more that's the way we grow our capacity
to produce as a country well sometimes
called the supply side of the economy
stimulating spending is dead easy
But ultimately it's what we produce that
determines long run growth and is there
any sort of specific policies that you
point to that could be helpful yeah so
think of it in two bits so roughly
speaking economics dead simple
you can expand the economy either by
growing the workforce
or by making that Workforce more
productive okay so on the first what can
we do to expand our Workforce bearing in
mind Sophie our Workforce has contracted
over the past couple of years by about
half a million people
that's why we've got one million
unfilled vacancies that's why every
sector and every region is screaming
blue murder about an absence of Staff
what could we do to expand the numbers
of people available and in work
well immigration is one safety valve
ruled out by both parties but it's
rightly run
wrongly
I think
um
and spread of skill shortages
for
not operating a little bit to alleviate
those through skilled controlled migrant
labor is a mistake inflation is
obviously a huge concern alongside
growth and something that all of our
viewers can be feeling yeah what's your
I mean we've seen the figures out
obviously still above 10 percent
how difficult do you think the Outlook
is for inflation or is it going to get
better
so it's been a very very difficult 18
months let's be absolutely clear we've
got inflation still in double digits
um and growth pretty much at zero that's
the wrong place on both fronts
the bad news and it is bad news because
we've seen the biggest squeeze on
household budgets over the past 18
months as we've seen since the 50s
actually
very difficult position
the good news is I think from here
from around the second half of the Year
things will begin to improve gradually
but they will begin to improve why do I
say that the world is getting a bit
better
not loads better but a bit better it's
getting its mojo back and that will help
us help us sell more of our stuff
overseas the big cause of that squeeze
on living standards has been high
inflation as you mentioned
that will begin
to head south pretty soon probably
starting next month actually and at a
rate of knots
because the biggest single reason why
it's picked up to 10 plus is because of
high energy prices and they have now
come off at a real rate of knots over
the course of the past six months and
that will start to show up
headline rates of inflation starting
pretty soon
you fast forward six months
I think the headline inflation rate will
not be double digits it might be three
four or five so we should see you next
Target then to halve inflation that
looks pretty safe pretty much nailed on
a lot of what I'm hearing from the
government is look we have to have pay
restraint because that fuels inflation
so increasing pay as obviously lots of
people in the public sector want to see
is a bad thing for the economy
well there's a question of balance there
it's certainly true
that
um one of the biggest single sources of
inflation is how much workers are paid
that's just a matter of the cost
arithmetic facing businesses
um and a degree of moderation whether in
the setting of wages but also in the
setting of prices by businesses
is necessary right now given that a
country given that as a country we are
somewhat poorer basically the price of
stuff that we buy from overseas has gone
up a lot
energy and food and that means as a
country we are somewhat poorer
the pain of that has been felt by
workers through pay and to an extent
like businesses in the form of reduced
profits and higher higher costs
nonetheless there is no question that
the way we grow as a country is by
having people's pay packets Rising
not falling over time and that I hope
and expect we'll see second half of the
year I'm interested to talk to you about
interest rates and mortgages as well
obviously you used to work for Bank of
England
our concerns are you about what is
happening when it comes to interest
rates how high do you think they might
go
yeah so we've seen them rise from almost
nothing
um to now what four and a quarter
percent which is a pretty chunky rise in
relatively short space of time and has
surprised lots of people
um
the big question is what happens next
I mean truth be told
even the rice so far Sophie has not been
felt
in most people's mortgage payments so
far many wrong fixed rates and those
fixed rates haven't reset yet
because the effects of the tightening
scene so far
haven't fully been felt and that would
personally had been back in my old job
at the bank of England set interest
rates which was my previous life for
seven years
that would give me cause for pause
I think hang on the economy is still on
steady legs right now
much the timing that's already happened
hasn't yet hit people's bank accounts
perhaps Now's the Time to press the
pause button and see what happens
because because of people's pain in the
mortgage rates and because it's going to
become difficult for in in this year
Well having faced a cost of living
squeeze if you're Rising the cost of
borrowing as well as the cost of living
that compounds the agony yeah and I'm
not sure right now whether businesses or
households are ready for the double
whammy of those two things
personally I'd be thinking hard about
pausing equally I think it's likely the
bank will feel the need to keep on
Rising further and financial markets
feel the same because those price
pressures and those wage pressures
remain well above the bank's two percent
Target I want to talk to you about
leveling up as well at your chair of the
leveling up advisory Council
it's one of those phrases that it's so
common we hear it all the time we had a
whole election campaign around it and
both sides of the house are using it
what do you think leveling up actually
means what is that about yeah well for
me it's it's um someone who grew up in a
pool place in the north uh it's about
unlocking the potential what did you
grow up uh in Yorkshire just north of
Leeds
I was born in Sunderland a place that
isn't doing well hasn't been doing well
for 70 years
so I know what leveling up feels like
um and I know what success looks like
you know in in my prayer life at the
bank of England I said most of my time
walking around the country
seeing the economy firsthand
place is doing well of which there are
many right now and places surfing far
less well so it's definitely an
achievable goal it's also a desirable
one this is about unlocking the
potential in people and in places which
is very very considerable what are the
ingredients for success is probably your
next question
somewhere seeing I think
um
you know the solution doesn't lie in
Whitehall hands it doesn't lie in
central government's hands it must lie
in local hands
this will only happen locally if it's
led by local people so the Devolution
agenda
the proliferation of Mayors I think is
really really important and on that you
know both parties are now leaning
heavily in to giving more power back to
the people it's interesting to talk
about your own sort of Journey from
Sunderland to some of the wealthiest
individuals and companies and areas of
the United Kingdom and for many people
they would say that to enable that
journey to happen for more people
you need to look at education yeah do
you think politicians are taking
education as seriously as they should no
I don't I think we we are not having a
conversation about education and
learning
and we need to we know that without that
we are pushing money and water uphill
uh so absolutely we need to build out
the skill based from the earliest of
yours through to a lifelong basis
to create you know we are chronically
short of people and skills in this
country more than 10 million people in
the workforce do not have their skills
they need for the workplace
half of all school kids half of all
school kids leave school loathing
learning rather than loving it that is
the worst endowment possible the one
thing you really want above all else for
our education system to do
is to embed a love of learning because
if you love it you'll keep on doing it
what's your idea about math to 18 is
that good idea so we are on an enumerate
relation and the prime minister is
absolutely right about that
the vice chair of national numeracy
would expect me to say it's a real
positive it is a real positive
um but one it's not about mathematics as
currently taught this is about basic
number skills can I add up can I
subtract can I make numbers for real and
helping me live my life pay for my
mortgage pay for my grocery bill
but it's also about other things
you know it's not just about stem
science technology engineering and maths
it's also about putting the a into stem
and making it steam Matt is to say arts
and humanities
what will protect us
from the rise of the machine from the
rise of AI is our creative capacity as
human beings and yeah that's often the
first thing to become in budgets it has
been we've seen the
the dwindling budgets for arts and
humanities the dwindling number of
people young people taking arts and
humanities
and that's a mistake that's a big
mistake for the jobs and skills of
tomorrow
really interesting stuff there from Andy
hunger and I thought the reflections he
had about Ai and how it actually could
be a creative skills that people value
is quite interesting maybe I would say
that as an English literature graduate
but who knows
um let's reflect shall we on what we've
been talking about this morning now we
can also look ahead to the political
week to come Lots on the agenda of
course with the build up the local
elections and an important Court battle
over those potential Rwanda deportations
well let's introduce two people that you
may be familiar with if you've been
watching the show over the last month or
so two women who certainly know their
way around Westminster a former
political advisor to labor Isha hazarika
and samashar who was a special advisor
to the conservative Home Secretary David
lovely to have you on both of you
um talk by my plant Dominic roll up to
start um it feels like everyone is
thrown in their two cents on this and
the reaction to the pool almost splits
down culture War lines but from two
people who really know what it's like to
be working in government in the Civil
Service as well I'm interested in that
relationship between ministers and the
civil service has it broken down is
there a problem and what's just what's
your view
so I think the relationship between
ministers and civil servants is actually
quite dysfunctional generally and so and
you're right there is this kind of like
cultural split about who's on you know
Dominic Robb's side and he's on the
Civil Service side and that is not the
right conversation to have in my view
there's a couple of steps back from this
which is have we ended up in a situation
where people don't feel that they're
able to either direct their civil
servants to do what they're supposed to
do be held accountable by Parliament and
by the electorates and how are civil
servants in a position where they don't
feel that they can talk back and there's
it was a really interesting article in
the Sun from an Insider anonymously
written about the state of the ministry
of justice and there was something that
really struck me which was there are
failings in our system that we are not
addressing and instead of doing things
like that we're actually talking about
what is essentially you know a
difficulty at the top rather than the
real policy guts of what needs to be
done in order to fix our prison system
for example so I think we all need to
take a bit of a step back and reflect on
really where is this dysfunction and how
are we going to fix it
I think my perspective is slightly
different I mean I started life off as a
Whitehall civil servant and then I
became a political advisor so I've kind
of been on both sides here and I think
for me it's a sign of a of a really
mediocre feeling minister to be at war
with your civil service now the Civil
Service most civil servants want to have
a good relationship with their minister
they like that proximity to power they
want to be part of a team which is
exciting Dynamic delivering big results
so I think this kind of argument that
somehow like all civil servants are you
know this weird term The Blob rude and
also a bit rude and also that they're
kind of activists you know it's I think
that does the Civil Service you know a
great disservice if you like and I think
if you're a smart Minister and if you're
a good special advisor I'm sure you are
a good special advisor when you're in
the home office you you realize that
having a good team which involves your
civil servants is absolutely Paramount
to delivering stuff and I think for all
this Bluster we hear from Dominic Robb
that he was some Titan of modern
politics and he's going to be this huge
loss to public life what did he actually
achieve you know he wasn't around when
the Afghanistan evacuation happened he
was famously still on holiday said that
the sea was closed and he presided over
a disaster at Justice you've said
yourself the justice system is is
absolutely
um crumbling there's so many things that
went wrong so I think this sort of
culture war of just you know having this
massive fight and blaming the civil
service for everything is really really
dangerous
the the difficulty is is that the system
is not set up well right if you were to
if you were to go back a minister goes
into a department and they don't really
know anybody there the brief they are
learning as they go on the job and they
don't have the power to hire or fire
anybody that's there so they they are
literally being dropped into this system
without any sort of understanding of how
it works I mean that's like a flawed way
of kind of managing it I totally take
your point that actually you do need to
help people learn how to be better
managers
um and in departments that they are not
used to and that they don't know their
way around and that there is something
on the other side of it as well because
even civil servants will say that the
system isn't working as well as it
should that has got lots of multifaceted
one of them being that they had two huge
shocks to the system one being brexit
and the second being the pandemic and
there needs to be some kind of
reappraisal not in the kind of Dominic
Cummings language of kind of like
blowing it all up but certainly even
within the Civil Service you will hear a
lot of gripes about how things could
work look better is there is there a
resistance in the Civil Service towards
specifically conservative policies
because it feels like this is the kind
of accusation from dominant ra that
people just didn't agree with what he
was doing and that's why he met
resistance well I think there's
sometimes there is a frustration or when
you're on the political side of things
and I saw this being a special advisor
where you know your minister wants the
department to deliver really quickly and
there's an issue about the the scale of
of the realism species and the reality
and also you know your Minister's
political career is hanging in the
balance because people like you and us
will be you know dissecting it on the
airwave so they want things to be
delivered but the civil service is there
to also make sure that ministers act
within the parameters of the law and
also to make sure that things are
realistic that they're cost effective
and that they are within like certain
kind of rules I mean that's one of the
the great functions of British democracy
having this sort of civil service that
is there yes to kind of Aid and help
Ministers of all political use depending
on who the government is but to make
sure that you are acting within
parameters and I just come back to this
point like the best ministers and the
best secretaries of State yes I do take
your point they go into new departments
they don't know people but they know how
to build teams for example you know you
know I was an opponent of George Osborne
you know when I was working for for Ed
Miller Band but certainly people I knew
at the treasury said that actually he
treated people really well that the
treasury people had a lot of time for
for him and I think it's not so much
that
civil servants are desperately morally
against the things that have been done a
lot of the ass and we know this because
stuff is being challenged and the
Court's left right and Center you look
at austerity you look at how things have
been cut it's very hard for people to
deliver when the kind of Foundations
aren't there whether it's sort of money
and resources and and realistic
expectations I I've got to say I don't
think it's unnecessarily a conservative
issue because I've definitely spoken to
labor and lib done people who've had the
same frustrations and the same problems
that Dominic Robb has spoken about
interesting
um I we're entering a local election
territory right uh where the campaigning
is ramping up we're in the kind of
campaign period and I'm entering that
slightly frustrating period with
politicians where everyone was very very
on brand and on message and there's a
lot of expectation management going on
right so I'm getting a straight answer
is hard ahead of the local elections
what are the conservatives firstly going
to be hoping for them I'll talk to you
so I think they're going to hope for a
sort of muted
um losses uh I don't think there's any
sense that they're gonna they think that
there's going to be kind of like a
massive Victory there so you're right
the expectation management has
absolutely begun
um I think that if they are able to hold
on to enough they can say that actually
this is just par for the course a
government that's been in a long time
and in the natural sort of um way of
things that this is what the results
have been I mean there was talk about at
one point about if it was a disastrous
result then Boris Johnson could be
waiting in the wings waiting to take
over is that now disappeared to see my
sense from people I'm speaking to is
that it's not really going to be the
moment that they all decide that
something's going to change now there
might be some kind of a plan of action
with Boris Loyalists and and Boris
people but whether there is enough of an
audience who wants to listen to that I
think that's been quite diminished I
think people just wanted a period of
calm so that they can actually build up
to go towards the general election and
Aisha and I were discussing this earlier
you know it is a big electoral test for
both Rishi sunak and Kia stamba so
I suppose the stakes are quite High yeah
Stakes high for Star as well right it is
interesting because this is like you
know it's going to be a sort of key test
probably the first the last set of
Elections possibly before we have the
next general election so this is really
important pitch ruling and the narrative
that both sides will be scrambling to
establish you know after the results are
really really important I mean the
conservatives are doing the classic and
management you know they're like we're
going to lose a billion seats
you know it's like it's kind of like
more seats than there are yes exactly
like every seat in the country we're
going to lose so there's that kind of
thing but what's going to be interesting
is is for is for Libra I think Libra
again I think muted is a good word I
think labor will be hoping that they'll
be kind of briefing sort of muted
expectations I think they'll be
definitely hoping to to win seeds I
think the the difficulty for labor is
going to be you know how big is that
number going to be and if it's not past
a certain threshold I mean what's also
going to be interesting is and we don't
talk about these it's going to be
interesting to see how the liberal
Democrats do and the greens do because
often in these local elections you know
there's lots of people particularly in
that blue wall area where I think a lot
of people could go liberal Democrat or
green so I think they're going to be
really interesting as well and I guess
the s p may be quite relief that there
aren't any in Scotland right and the SMP
is having another
um Torrid week you know we saw the the
treasurer Colin Beatty have to stand
aside you know there was a big moment
for Hamza Yusuf to try and reset things
but of course the whole thing is
dominated by yet more arrests I mean
it's not good when you're the first
Minister and you have to say yes I was
surprised when one of my colleagues was
we are not a criminal operation you know
it's so I think you know he's he's
trying to do these resets and then
there's this the Specter of more arrests
hanging over and of course now there are
rumors swirling around that there will
be you know potentially even Nicholas
sturgeon might be called in for
questioning as well so there's there's
still that huge moment of anxiety for
the msmp we learn as well that the party
still owes Peter Murrell money um as
well so it is a really tough time and of
course there was a an opinion pool this
week which shows that support for the s
p has dropped to the lowest level since
2014 so all of this Scandal is really
doing a lot of damage to this very new
first Minister and it feels like the
kind of sins of the the fathers and the
mothers that went before him are hanging
over him now difficult start isn't it
for the new leader incredibly difficult
and actually I don't see how he comes
back from this because there is as you
say there was attempted to relaunch it
sort of putting out his vision uh for
his leadership but it's seems to be
completely ignored and how does one
actually navigate when there's always
going to be these stories and this thing
hanging over him I I don't think it's
possible for him to have a successful
run at this wow big big um difficulties
there uh really interesting to talk to
you both and get your analysis we'll
speak to you very soon indeed well
that's it for this week's at Sofia Ridge
on Sunday but in a moment after the
break we're going to be running through
today's interviews and having a chat
with our Deputy political editor sound
codes thanks for joining us this Sunday
morning
[Music]
hello welcome back you are watching
Sophie Ridge on Sunday the take a chance
to look back at our interviews this
morning on the program and try and work
out what we've learned what it means for
the week ahead now it's an interesting
week because when Oliver dad and was
first confirmed as being on the program
he had one job title uh that changed
within 24 hours and it was while this
week while we knew that he was on the
program that it got upgraded to Deputy
Prime Minister because he closed on our
vicious Scenic was told that he was
going to be stepping into the shoes of
Dominic Robb another Minister who had to
resign over a scandal a difficulty of
course after the reports into his
behavior as Minister and his actions
towards the civil service is this
something that is going to stick to
Rishi sunak ahead of those all-important
local elections or will people perhaps
that take a bit more of a nuanced view
well we can try and find out this
morning we're going to look back at some
of our interviews we're also joined by
our Deputy political editor Sam coats to
try and have that discussion Sam lovely
to have you as always is what did you
make of the Olive Garden interview
well it's good to get him three days
into the job all of it down then might
not have the highest profile of any
cabinet minister although I think that's
rapidly changing but he is at the heart
of Rishi sunak's operation arguably even
closer to Richardson than his ex Dex
prime minister
um Dominic Robb he does the oversees the
election uh uh kind of preparations he's
overseeing the relations with the Civil
Service there's a cabinet office
Minister he's been at the heart of what
um uh the prime minister is trying to do
so what Oliver Dowden says is key and
what I was watching out for in that
interview was basically whether the
right hand man of the Prime Minister
agreed with Dominic Robb that he was
treated unfairly that there's a big
problem at the heart of the Civil
Service uh or not and he didn't so this
is as you have been talking about it's
effectively this culture war is the
Civil Service fit for purpose is the
Civil Service politically resistant to
Services ideas of the sort that were
being pushed by Dominic Robb when he was
Secretary of State for justice or is it
something a little less confrontational
and the uh sort of the circumstances
around uh Dominic Robb perhaps just a
little bit more unique to him and and
for all the warm words about Dominic
Raab Oliver Daven didn't effectively
agree with him I thought the Nuance the
fact that he didn't say there was a big
problem with the Civil Service the fact
that he said that he could get them to
do what he wanted was very significant
but whether or not it'll dampen down the
Tory row over all of this I'm not sure
but certainly it doesn't look like Rishi
sunak and his new number two want to
lean into it you're right let's have a
listen shall we to what Oliver Darden
said because as Sam was saying it did
look like he was carefully trying to
support the Civil Service lesson
I didn't live Dom's experience I've I've
served both as an advisor in the past
and for a number of years as a cabinet
minister I've always found that if you
give clear instructions to Civil Service
of course you can have frustrations and
believe me I've had my frustrations as
well but I've also seen for example I
think that at the height of the covid
crisis I when all of our theaters were
were locking down my civil servants
worked Relentless with me Leslie with me
uh that was all of Darwin's take I put
the same thing to Jonathan Ashworth
asking him how concerned we should be
that a senior cabinet minister is
talking about civil servants in that way
let's listen
there's no problem with being demanding
our inquisitorial or pushing the system
hard
I want to be the work and pension
secretary I want to be demanding and
push the system to get people into good
well-paid jobs to lift children out of
poverty to help the disabled people a
million extra disabled people in poverty
I want to push hard and be demanding to
give pensioners security so there's
nothing wrong with that but the report
found that Dominic Robb was intimidating
aggressive and it's not just that he was
a bullying Minister he was also a
failing minister
so that was the takes of our two main
guests on the program this morning let's
bring Sam back in uh shall we does this
mean this is all going to kind of go
away now or is it something that's going
to keep rambling on
I think it'll keep running rumbling on I
mean notice what was going on there
playing those two little excerpts of the
interviews back to back that in effect
they are in agreement uh neither
individual neither the conservative
Deputy Prime Minister nor the labor
Shadow cabinet minister wanted to say
that there's a politicized civil service
uh that is fighting the agenda of of
ministers and that is just quite
interesting but you have uh a sort of a
part of the conservative party looking
forward uh and trying to prosecute this
uh argument and one of the reasons that
they're able to do that is
if I'm being completely honest uh
sayfield we spend all day on Friday
picking over this report into Dominic
Robb's Behavior by Adam Tolley is that
while it may have been legally uh very
sound politically it was the base
unsatisfactory document because
politically I think whether it's the
prime minister or the public you wanted
some clarity but it was very very
nuanced whether it was on the behavior
of Dominic Robb which at some points
intimidated people or left them feeling
intimidated but made clear that he
wasn't intending to intimidate and he
wasn't picking on individuals even if
individuals felt that they were being
bullied and also pointed to perhaps some
things on the Civil Service side that
might point to coordination to try and
work against it but all of this means
the picture is very muddy and allows all
sides to do it because what I think what
I really think about the the Dominic Rob
Affair is that they have just been
questions about how he conducted himself
for years Sophie and and I think that's
it's very hard to reflect that in uh in
a legal document but but I was reading
45 minutes ago when when when I popped
up earlier that excerpt
um from the very well regarded historian
Auntie Anthony Selden who talked about
civil servants in number 10 being warned
about uh Dominic Ralph's Behavior ahead
of him coming in in 2010 to step in for
Boris Johnson and and that kind of red
flag around a a culture uh in his office
of being problematic
um you know that seeped through to the
likes of you and me for for a very long
time and the question is uh is this just
a government that when it knows that
there's a a problem but perhaps it
hasn't got it down in black and white
you know the nose of the Prime Minister
just um wrinkles and and leads them
together maybe I won't put them in
cabinet
um or is this a government that plays
hear no evil and see no evil and the
most effective bit of your interview
with Oliver dad was just putting a whole
series of other things to him whether it
was whether or not they were right to
appoint Richard Sharp who perhaps it's
got a bit too close to Boris Johnson
whether it's right for the prime
minister to tell the Monarch that uh
Boris Johnson dad Stanley Johnson should
be uh elevated to the House of Lords
worth pointing out of course that Boris
Johnson's already put his brother uh in
the House of Lords you know all of these
things I think the accusation The Wider
accusation is does this government just
play a bit dumb when there are some
politically inconvenient but
nevertheless a fairly big warning flags
and and I think that's the question uh
that labor will be trying to capitalize
on and and is in the heart of politics
at the moment yeah
by layering those things together by
putting them together because what it
does is to give you a sense of this
isn't just one thing where look there is
a nuanced argument and you can hear both
sides it said these things start
layering up then there is is there an
overall impression as you say that this
is a hear no evil see no evil uh
government well look we've got the uh
elections coming up at scene so we'll
try it and find out a bit more about
them we'll have some more from Sam in a
moment because we did talk a bit about
those at local elections on the program
the Deputy Prime Minister himself
telling me he thinks his party is going
to lose around a thousand seats in them
so that is a bit of expectation
management going on we heard from the
liberal Democrat leader so Ed Davey as
well let's have a little listen to what
he says his focuses on these elections
I think the conservatives have let down
our country very very badly that's what
conservative voters are telling us
whether it's on economy on the Health
Service or on the the environment for
example what I feel is that liberal
Democrats and all politicians frankly
should respond to the electorate make it
clear where they stand on those issues
and not take voters for granted I mean
in many ways your question is taking
voters for granted now I'm not going to
do that I want to make sure that we earn
people's vote over the weeks and months
ahead so at the next general election we
can get rid of this a shocking
government
you probably saw my slightly quizzical
face on screen there it's always a bit
weird to see yourself back on TV I have
to say um and the reason I was looking a
bit confused is because the question I
was asking uh numerous times there was
whether or not the lib dance would go
into a coalition with labor I wasn't
really clear let's bring in Sam coats at
this time shall we
um how are the liberal Democrats and
does it matter that they're not giving a
straight answer to these things or is it
actually sensible politics
so I actually thought that we learned
quite a lot from the way the manner that
Ed David dodged your question there
if you if you read behind between the
lines you know the reason you were
asking that question is that one of the
completely possible outcomes from the
next general election will be a hung
Parliament and in the event that no
party gets an overall majority
um the MP is going to effectively work
together and vote on who they should
make prime minister which uh party
should Supply the person that goes in
number 10. and there are all sorts of
different ways that you can do that and
the conservatives obviously tied up with
the liberal Democrats between 2010 and
2015 worked very well for the tour is a
bit of a disaster for the liberal
Democrats in 2015 but that was a formal
Coalition in other words there was an
agreement at the start that they stuck
to amazingly all the way through and
there was some liberal Democrat policy
priorities that were delivered and Nick
Clegg was Deputy Prime Minister and that
model worked out really badly for the
liberal Democrats which is I think why
they're not jumping on the idea that
they would do that again but then
there's a slightly more nuanced question
which is we've got to have a prime
minister the the MPS have to work
together so if the liberal Democrats
were the swing voters in a parliament
um would they back the labor party going
in or would they back the conservative
party going and and I think from the
tone from the tone of Ed Davey basically
saying he was the party his is the party
to defeat the conservatives uh and and
using pretty Punchy language it eats
very hard to see a Ed davey-led liberal
Democrat uh government a sort of party
after the next election voting to put
the conservative party in government
given everything that he's talking there
wasn't much criticism at play but there
was loads of very sharp criticism
against the conservatives I don't think
he could ever back them to go into Power
one um one coder to all of that in the
2019 election uh many many liberal
Democrat leaders ago Joe Swinson tried
to claim that she could be the Prime
Minister herself and that was an
absolute disaster for the liberal
Democrats nobody believed her and they
had to abandon that strategy halfway
through the election to the other option
for him to say which is I'm going to be
PM uh probably not credible and not
sensible so so hinting that he would put
labor in power without saying so but
making clear the Tories of the enemy I
think gives us a very clear steer uh
where the lib Dems might and how they
might behave after the next election
depending on the numbers that's really
interesting and also it matters for the
elections coming up too because they're
an awful lot of those blue wall
constituencies their lib duns will be
targeting as well
that's right for labor to do well the
liberal Democrats need to do well uh as
well and um you can see informally the
country being divided up into into areas
where labor are going to take on the
Tories and areas uh perhaps in the south
south east where the um where the
liberal Democrats are going to take on
uh uh the Tories there are some areas
where labor and the lib Dems fight it
out but that that's the non-minority and
and given that sort of sense of informal
uh uh working uh where people put
resources into one uh or the other but
not uh but not both parties fighting the
Tories doing that you you do I do get
just the sort of outline uh of um of the
country being divided up by two parties
that want to kick out the Tories from
number 10. really interesting well if
the conservative party are going to have
any hope of doing well not just at the
locals but also at the election next
year it's got a half Something's Gonna
Have to happen with inflation now we're
joined on the program uh by the bank of
England's former Chief Economist Aldi
howdain and I thought it was quite
interesting what he had to say about
inflation listen
the world's getting a bit better not
loads better but a bit better it's it's
getting its mojo back and that will help
us help us sell more of our stuff
overseas the big cause of that squeeze
on living standards has been high
inflation as you mentioned
that will begin
to head south pretty soon probably
starting next month actually and at a
rate of knots
well let's bring in our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates shall we and that's
going to be good news isn't it for the
Prime Minister heading south soon at a
rate of knots
yeah it's really hard to overstate how
important what Andy helden just said the
entire political Outlook could change in
a matter of months look for all of the
sleeves and the you know 13-year Legacy
of Tory LED government going back to
2010 that labor are trying to capitalize
on in the end the economics who will put
more money in people's pocket who has
been the better or would be the better
Steward of the economy is perhaps the
most important question in British
politics and how we feel now might be
very different to how we feel in the
start of 2024 and that's certainly uh
what the conservatives are are hoping is
the case they hope inflation will be
right down they'll be able to deliver
tax cuts they'll be able to put money uh
back in people's pockets and then they
might have a real shot at the next
election but
it is not at all clear to me that people
will be quite so forgiving you know
inflation at 10 now means that so many
things are so much more expensive than
they were a year ago no chance of price
is going down just the rate at which
prices go up might slow a bit so is
there a wholesale change in the way that
uh that voters think about it given that
in the two-year period that Rishi Sue
that's been in in power things that have
gone up in cost uh so much food prices
of course just under 20 higher uh than
they than they are but it's also a
challenge for labor because as politics
changes their arguments need to to
change as well and and I feel listening
to a lot of Labor politicians that
they're really still fighting as if Liz
truss was in number 10 they're
highlighting the chaos The Economist
management uh the the uncertainty around
interest rates and while that will have
some purchase you know people's
mortgages are going to be more expensive
particularly if you were one of those
tragically unlucky people that had to
remortgage uh when the after effects of
the Liz trust mini budget were in place
I think at the same time they need to be
able to present a much much clearer
picture and to be honest I'm getting a
lot of concern from labor figures that
they haven't nailed the arguments nailed
the campaigning language that they're
not presenting a clear enough Vision as
well so opportunities for both sides but
dangers for both sides but just that
sense that politics is going to be very
different in six months time means that
people who confidently tell you they
know what's going to happen uh in either
May or October or maybe even the
following January uh February or March
you know you just can't be sure yeah
it's absolutely right isn't it it was so
interesting listening to Andy hundane
and saying that about interest rates
coming down or inflation rates already
come down at a rate of knots and also
saying that look but she's seeing its
Target to have inflation he described as
nailed on I mean that was as confident
as you could possibly get but as Sam
says it's all about how people feel it
in their pockets always good to uh talk
uh Sam uh Sam there with his analysis on
all the interviews of this program but
also of course looking ahead to the week
because things are really going to be
hotting up ahead of those local
elections votes in England and also in
Northern Ireland you can also listen to
the interviews from the program on our
podcast safety Ridge on Sunday podcast
which should be available around
lunchtime that will be with myself our
editor Scott Beasley and also Jess algo
on the guardian that's it from Sophie
Ridge on Sunday the take this morning
thank you so much for being with us this
morning we'll see you next week
foreign
[Music]